this is a super quick video for all the
women entrepreneurs out there in believe
nation that I am looking at crude in a
new series probably once a month called
girlboss and I just love the idea be
able to showcase women entrepreneurs in
their own series for all the little
girls kind of watch insane I could be
like that too so if you are a fan of the
girl boss series I would love to know
from the women watching on this channel
who should I feature in the first girl
boss video is probably a mix up of 8 to
10 different women who do you want to
see and again the market I'm looking at
younger women girls for role models to
look up to so that if there's a girl in
high school who wants to be an
entrepreneur but is doubting herself and
then sees this video and looks at all of
these successful women who've made it on
their own that's what I want to showcase
and so who are those women that would be
inspirational to that high school girl
who wants to make it on her own
please please please leave a comment let
me know down below and I'm really
looking forward to launching this series
thank you for the love guys continue to
believe and whatever your one where it
is
much love if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you that
sums you Apple so it would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details